the Harry Potter series has been a
consistent source of magic for more than
two decades white kids but not all of
the silver screen adaptations of JK
Rowling's works have turned out as well
as others from pacing issues too
distracting book to screen
inconsistencies to moments of shoddy
direction
some of the films simply don't measure
up to the rest so let's walk through all
of the Harry Potter films starting with
the best and counting down to find out
which one of them is officially the
worst Harry Potter movie ever made
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
there was the Harry Potter franchise
before Prisoner of Azkaban
and there was the Harry Potter franchise
after director Alfonso Cuaron brought
more than just fresh eyes to the series
third installment he brought a whole new
perspective to the magical franchise by
grounding it in humanity cuarón had the
benefit of prior films world-building
already in place of course but he also
brought a great deal of style and
gravity to the story and helped to
darken the mood and ramp up the sense of
true danger in the movies just in time
even from the film's opening moments the
film seems more alive than before with
performances that rang a little more
true the energy of the movie is electric
and draws us into Harry's life and ways
the first two films hadn't that's why is
the Dementors attacks on him are so
frightening and why Sirius Black's
character arc is utterly compelling to
watch not only did the film wander back
to Hogwarts it also fundamentally
altered the direction of the franchise
and became a benchmark for the entire
series to follow Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix by the time the
fifth Harry Potter film came along the
series was starting to barrel towards
its in game Voldemort has already
returned and lives are being lost as a
result the days of caring about house
points and sneaking through the
restricted section are certainly over
for Harry ins pals and in addition to
the looming dangers of the outside order
of the Phoenix really brings at home
when Dolores Umbridge rushers the
authoritarianism rising within the
Ministry of Magic to the halls of
Hogwarts Harry and those loyal to
Dumbledore must band together in secret
to survive a rain and yet it feels like
a hopeless endeavor and causes a sense
of dread that's very real for audiences
at home unlike many of its predecessors
order of the Phoenix never feels
overwhelmed by its narrative ambition it
plugs along at a brisk pace
covering the bases including the series
first full-on wizard fights and develops
one of the series biggest emotional
payoffs in its harrowing final moments
it was director David Yates first foray
into the franchise and it's easy to see
why they kept him around after this
movie struck so many high notes Harry
Potter and the half-blood Prince in many
ways half-blood Prince actually beats
order the Phoenix on the dramatic front
the film's impact is bolstered by a
devastating third act the film finds
Harry and friends continuing to fight
the good fight while unraveling the deep
dark secret that made Voldemort all but
immortal and it's a thrill to watch as
the stakes get raised to immeasurably
scary levels structured more as a pulpy
detective story than a magical adventure
tale half-blood prince is the one film
in the series that can be qualified as a
genuine slow burner it introduces the
element of Horcruxes of Snape's ulterior
motives and decimates any sense of
safety that might have remained before
half-blood Prince may test your patience
with his pacing and certain creative
liberties in the plot might hurt Potter
purists but it does deliver on the drama
and nimbly sets into motion this series
Big Finish Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part-2 due to the final books
length and density Warner Brothers
decided to split the last installment of
the series into two films with the hopes
that David Yates and his team could give
the franchise to send-off it deserved
and earn an extra helping of profits of
course despite a wobbly start with part
1 yates managed to achieve a fitting end
with Deathly Hallows part-2 the closing
chapter covers Harry Hermione and Ron's
desperate search for Voldemort's
Horcruxes Snape surprising history the
epic battle of Hogwarts and Harry's
fateful showdown with the last heir of
Slytherin it's a lot of action and drama
to sift through for one film and some
fans have expressed disappointment with
the way the final showdown between Harry
and the Dark Lord plays out but with the
many smaller battles and moments of epic
heroism on display in the end Deathly
Hallows still ends with a bang as long
as you turn it off before the silly
epilogue that is fantastic beasts and
where to find them
JK Rowling decided to travel back to the
past for the series next cinematic
adventure fantastic beasts and where to
find them which she scripted follows the
little-known character Newt Scamander in
1920s New York as he inadvertently
unleashes a bevy of
magical creatures into the muggle realm
the Big Apple proves to be a welcome
change of scenery for Rowling's world
free from the world of owl exams and
teen angst the more grown-up tale of
Wizards wandering the world feels fresh
and offers a new lens through which to
view the magical realm the film is
filled with action-adventure and
frightening foes but the human element
of the story is front and center which
makes it a little less draining than
some of its predecessors that said it
suffers from some very slow moments and
a sense of direction lessness that makes
the film feel very choppy and with the
forthcoming sequel the crimes of
Grindelwald just around the corner we
can expect this sub series to start
building back up to an all-out war
sooner rather than later
which might make fantastic beasts to
feel formulaic Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 1 there are a lot
of things that do work about Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 1
for starters it successfully sets up the
Big Finish and offers some moments of
emotional a vocation that hadn't yet
been seen in the series it also
separates the trio from everything
they've ever known and puts the whole
Horcrux hunt on the fast track however
despite the film's stylish scenery and
some gutting performances by the leading
trio of cast mates the film is pretty
boring and seems to unnecessarily eat up
screen time with characters sitting
around just to justify making the final
installment a two-parter the animated
mini movie and dobby's Last Stand were
standout moments of the whole series but
Deathly Hallows Part 1 could have still
been reduced to half an hour or so and
tacked on to the following film and fans
wouldn't have missed out on much it's
true every would Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire after cheating death for
three straight years
Harry's fourth year at Hogwarts proved
to be his most perilous yet Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire finds the
tortured teen wizard competing as the
youngest ever contestant in the
Triwizard Tournament and facing down the
murderous Dark Lord Himself Voldemort
although the tournament setting does
offer a nice contrast between the kids
Vance ville youth with the true grimness
of the world that surrounds them the
movie also suffers from some pretty
cringe-worthy acting
take my body back
take my body back it's my father it also
fails to find nuance in the secondary
characters like Cedric Diggory and Cho
Chang which means their emotional arcs
fall flat the best part of the film is
when Harry and Voldemort finally come
face to face but the whole encounter is
limited to just a few minutes and feels
like an afterthought that's overshadowed
by far less important drama Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone credit is due
to Christopher Columbus for constructing
a beautiful vision of Hogwarts and the
intricacies of magic found in JK Rowling
story in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone and ultimately his casting choices
for most of the characters would prove
to pay off big-time in the long run
however with the kids being so young in
the earliest installment their line
deliveries leave something to be desired
and the film feels more like a cheery
Disney movie than the start of a long
hard battle for the Boy Who Lived
with its three-headed beasts
shape-shifting professors flying brooms
and a larger-than-life chess match
though there's still some major magic to
behold in Harry's first year at Hogwarts
in the end this first installment of the
landmark franchise is just magical
enough to keep your attention but it's
also a bit of a snoozer on repeat
viewings Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets Chris Columbus has returned to
adapt the second Harry Potter
installment Chamber of Secrets is even
less impressive than the first chirp the
film offers up a genuine sense of
discovery and even danger to the famed
school surrounded by whomping willows
spider filled forests and the titular
Chamber of Secrets and all of this
happens just as Harry and his friends
began to unravel the dark and twisted
history of Tom Riddle unfortunately
Chamber of Secrets still sees its stars
struggling to find their way as actors
while the director misses big moments
with poor tone and pacing choices as
well
there are no bad installments to the
Harry Potter film series of course but
with this one sidestepping so many
potential power punches written into the
book storyline
well it's arguably the least magical of
them all
[Music]
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]